هو الحب وذوق الجمالي والانساني ما ابسط
الاحلام ما اعظم الانسان ما اصغر المكان
ما اكبر الفكره بهذه الكلمات انطلق مهرجان
فلسطين الدولي
[موسيقى]
انها رساله الاسير المفكر المريض وليد دقه
لابنته ميلاد التي لا يعرفها رساله
المهرجان كانت اولا للاسرى والشهداء وان
الاحتلال لن يحاصره الفلسطينيين
اقيم المهرجان في الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين
لنكبه فلسطين وشعاره مفتاح العوده
المفتاح
وايضا هذا المفتاح يعلق على صدورنا وفي
بيوتنا لكي نقول ان حق العوده لا يسقط
بالتقادم
فرقه ابيدر تضم فنانين من اسبانيا والسويد
والاهم من فلسطينيين هجرت عائلاتهم عاما
نكبه
الاوركسترا العربيه اكثر من 70 عازفا
وهذا الشاب الذي يعزف على اليرغول من مخيم
جنين الحاضر بعد العدوان
من مصر والاردن ودول غربيه
جميعهم وجدوا ان الغناء في فلسطين ليس كاي
مكان
فلسطين بالنسبه لالي مثل الحلم انا اليوم
سعيد انه انا موجوده هون وبنفس الوقت
الغناء رساله لانه احنا بنحاول نحافظ على
التراث الاصيل
اما الغائب الحاضر فهم الشهداء من بينهم
عضو الهيئه الاداريه للمهرجان شيرين ابو
عاقل
[موسيقى]
لون البرتقالي بزرفه البحر وخيوط الثوب
بجذور الزيتون فكان مفتاح العوده شعار
المهرجان ليؤكد مجددا على ان الثقافه
والفنون توحد الشعوب وتخترق جدران الصمت
وتنقل فلسطين الى العالم